wo wir beim thema sind gleich hier um
die ecke neben unserem studio
veranstaltet birte schneider momentan
einen ganz besonderen
geburtsvorbereitungskurs frau schneider
was es denn bei ihnen das besondere
also ich versuche hier die werdenden
eltern in entspannter atmosphäre so
sanft wie möglich darauf vorzubereiten
dass sie einen furchtbaren fehler
gemacht haben
unsere erste übung ist ganz simpel jeder
von euch gebt mir jetzt mal alles
bargeld was er dabei hat ja super viele
gedanken schön alles supi und jetzt ja
jetzt haben die kein geld mehr das heißt
jetzt kennen sie ihre finanzielle
situation für die nächsten 25 jahre
er kriegt von mir noch einen tupfer
döschen da könnte die plazenta
einfrieren
für schlechte zeiten was diese beiden
kegelrobben und ihre menschen nämlich
noch nicht an
wir sind jetzt schon zu spät dran für
alles hebamme krankenhaus kita alles
längst ausgebucht ja aber moment mal es
gibt doch einen rechtsanspruch auf
kita-betreuung natürlich rechtsanspruch
zur not kommt die merkel persönlich und
passt auf ihre kinder auf
rechtsanspruch über 290.000 plätze für
kinder unter drei fehlen allein nrw hat
eine betreuungslücke von über 16 prozent
und die wut darüber die hecheln wir
jetzt mal gemeinsam back ok superschön
super ganz ganz toll auch mit der neuen
gruppe gibt es keine gesetzlich
geregelte ganztagsbetreuung für
grundschüler dass mutti kann auch in
zukunft maximal teilzeit arbeiten
für diesen fall habe ich aber eine ganz
tolle wickel tuch technik entwickelt und
zwar um sogar mit zwillingen vollzeit zu
arbeiten hier so kann man schon stunden
nach der geburt wieder pizza ausliefern
das hier ist eine sehr sehr schöne übung
für männer der tiefrote vier füße auf
allen vieren beim chef battle damit die
zwei monate elternzeit auch christin zu
stehen
friedhelm kannst du bitte ein bisschen
tiefer buckeln tiefer tiefer
das war schon sehr schön habe ich sehe
immer noch rückgrat
ja das sieht nicht schön aus aber wenn
man seine würde behalten bilder darf man
halt keine kinder kriegen was immer das
ist ja furchtbar was die da machen
das ist ehrlich so und jetzt nehmen die
frauen bitte mal ihren sitz ball
schlagen in sich rhythmisch vor die
stirn und denken dabei still warum war
ich so doof in deutschland schwanger zu
werden und die männer legen sich so
lange auf den rücken machen sie sich
bitte ganz bequem ja friedrich super und
jetzt ein bisschen die beine breit und
dann zeige ich ihnen meine tolle technik
die künftige schwangerschaften sicher
vermeidet somit wim van thiel sparte
schweinberger damen und herren
[Applaus]